marie mallet est une habituée de tik tok
au point de transformer son salon en
studio improvisé
toc toc d'enfance c'est une application
se placer ta créativité débordés or non
elle a créé 500 petite vidéo appréciés
plus d'un million cinq cent mille fois
aujourd'hui
elle a presque cent mille abonnés
l'organisme eye vidéo monde étant donné
le goût d'essayer juste pour le fun ses
missions ses conseils de ses vidéos les
plus populaires
cette adaptation de françois pérusse je
peux passer une journée assez
d'apprendre un texte dans ma voiture
avec environ un milliard d'utilisateurs
tik tok est devenu un phénomène très
fréquenté pour marie c'est aussi pour le
plaisir essentiel de se changer les
idées parce que dans la vraie vie elle
est d'abord et avant tout préposé aux
bénéficiaires dans un ch et celle des
envies toujours un stress on se demande
toujours comment est ce quelqu'un qui
m'a d'avoir quelqu'un il mettra l'aï
quand même payer ce qu'il y aurait dans
le dépôt tout comme bien d'autres
personnes qui travaillent dans la santé
en pleine crise faire des vidéos est
devenu presque thérapeutique
surtout après des journées de 16 à 12
le lendemain de son entretien vidéo pour
assez de penser à autre chose
j'adore on entend quand les cloches qui
sonnent en décroche poule histoire de
partager sa bonne humeur et son petit
côté clown
elle a invité ses collègues et ses
patients dans ces vidéos
en plus ré qui était émotif pourquoi ça
leur touche c'est normal c'est leur
métier puis session si on est comme une
famille le succès de la vidéo lui a fait
chaud au coeur
j'avais près 400 commentaires qu au sein
du positif c'est de l'encouragement non
ça fait vraiment du bien de voir qu'on
est appuyé vraiment merci
bref de quoi inspirer davantage pour le
plaisir
moi c'est parce que j'aime ça fait rire
j'ai absolument ce important un avis de
l'humour et beaucoup d'amour qui réussit
à traverser les barrières du confinement
ici frédéric arnold radio canada glavine